afghan forces have clashed with taliban
fighters in an operation to retake a key
border crossing with pakistan
the unrest at spin boldac follows weeks
of growing violence
as the taliban filled the void left by
u.s troops
the security situation is stretching
government forces to their limits
and forcing many people to leave the
country
desperate and looking for a way out
hundreds gather at this close border
crossing between
afghanistan and pakistan with whatever
there's a war going on between the
government and the taliban on the other
side
the border is closed they have to stop
fighting and let us go through
so we can go home battles between
afghan forces and taliban fighters have
escalated across the country in recent
weeks
there are various challenges to cover
this kind of story
on friday award-winning photojournalist
denise shadiq
was killed near spinballdoc's crossing
he was embedded with special forces when
the military
attempted to regain control of the
crossing it's an economic lifeline for
southern afghanistan
a crucial artery for exporting farm
goods
controlling it would be an economic
windfall for the taliban
insurgents recent attacks seemed
tactical taking advantage of nato and
u.s troop withdrawal
u.s president joe biden has made it
clear nation building was not part of
the war on terror launched 20 years ago
he says it's time to leave afghanistan's
future to its people
russia's foreign minister took a swipe
at biden calling the mission a failure
let's face the truth as president biden
has confirmed
americans left because they considered
their mission accomplished
obviously he tried to present the
situation in the best way possible
but everyone understands their mission
failed
even as districts topple to the taliban
afghan leaders look with optimism
towards peace talks in doha
they say peace will only come from the
negotiating table
and not the battlefield
and for more on this i'm joined by
journalist ali latifi in herat
afghanistan uh ali the government and
troops and the taliban have both
declared victory in the fight at the
spin
boldac crossing who's actually right
here
in reality it could be that both are
right because what we've seen
over the last few weeks is that what
exactly what just happened
is that the taliban will claim to take
over a place
and then not long after the government
will
take to have retaken that place um
and that's really been the pattern over
the last few weeks
and is there a significant risk that the
taliban will
take back power after the american and
nato troops leave
the risk exists but you know the
question is if they're not able to keep
these districts if they're not able to
keep these
uh checkpoints along the duran line or
these border crossings with iran
um or if they weren't even able to keep
you know the capital of badrich province
which is actually a small capital
um it leads a lot to to
question whether or not they could take
a major city like kandar or
jalalabad they haven't shown yet that
they can really sustain their control
over an area okay uh journalist ali
latifi in herat afghanistan thanks so
much for
that update thank you
you